if you're training for a hardcore goal  you're going to get depleted like  they're you're going to be pushed and  challenged and that's okay that's part  of the whole deal right and there's  something to be gleaned and learned  about yourself from that experience and  this is part of why we sign up to do  hard things but ultimately in the long  run it has to be more nourishing than  depleting because you're getting so into  the performance piece that it's not as  fun as it used to be or it's not it's  not as joyous as when you began so let's  cure that by  incorporating into your training routine  some fun runs where you don't have the  Garment on you take off the heart rate  monitor and you just go get lost in the  woods or you go out with friends and you  have a good time the joy is the  sustainable energy that will keep you in  the sport you know for many years to  come